The breeze that you're feeling isn't a storm
headed your way.
No, it's a sign that the rumor mill is churning
once again, delivering to us an interesting
bit of speculation about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
A recent report by We Got This Covered claims
that Marvel Studios is looking to bring the
superhero Moon Knight to the screen, and is
eyeing a former Spider-Man star to portray
him.
Citing an unidentified source, the outlet
contends that Moon Knight will likely get
his own movie in the MCU, and that he could
be played by Andrew Garfield, who embodied
the web-slinging vigilante in 2012's The Amazing
Spider-Man and its ill-fated 2014 follow-up
The Amazing Spider-Man 2.
"What?"
"Yeah.
But I'm really excited!"
We Got This Covered alleges in another report
that Marvel wants a movie focused on Moon
Knight rather than a series that would end
up on Disney+.
The company is also reportedly aiming to get
a Jewish actor to play the role of the nocturnal
hero, who has Jewish heritage, with a father
who's a Rabbi.
Moon Knight's alter ego is a man named Marc
Spector who suffers from dissociative identity
disorder.
While many people regard him as being simply
crazy, he also becomes the emissary of the
Egyptian God Khonshu, gaining supernatural
powers and stylizing himself as a caped crime-fighter.
"This looks like Khonshu.
It's bad enough having that Moon God sitting
in my head pulling my strings.
Now he wants to have a line of toys, too?"
While the rumor hasn't been substantiated
outside of WGTC, Garfield would fit the bill
of what Marvel is reportedly looking for.
The actor is known to have Polish-Jewish ancestry,
his family surname is said to have originally
been "Garfinkel," and his paternal grandparents
were part of Jewish immigrant families.
While Garfield has described himself as religiously
being more of an agnostic, he does identify
as Jewish and is proud of his Jewish heritage.
The idea of Garfield joining the MCU in his
post-Spider-Man days to become Moon Knight
is pretty mind-boggling, but, truth be told,
this rumor is very thin.
The famously secretive Marvel Studios hasn't
said a peep about whether a movie or series
about Moon Knight is even a possibility.
Studio president Kevin Feige has been known
to keep a zipped lip on details about future
projects, but he did loosen up a great deal
during 2019's San Diego Comic-Con.
At the event, Marvel held its hotly-anticipated
presentation at which the complete slate of
films and TV series that will comprise Phase
4 of the MCU was announced.
Feige even revealed that a Blade reboot starring
Mahershala Ali was in the works, and confirmed
that Black Panther 2, Captain Marvel 2, Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3, a Fantastic Four movie,
and a film about the X-Men were all underway
at Marvel.
There wasn't a word about Moon Knight - not
for the far-off, unannounced Phase 5, and
certainly not for Phase 4.
Now, just because Feige and his fellow Marvel
executives haven't said anything about developing
a movie centered on Moon Knight doesn't mean
that it won't ever happen in the future.
But there's no solid information to suggest
that this rumor is true.
And though We Got This Covered notes that
the intel about Garfield being eyed to play
Marvel's Moon Knight comes from a source with
a, quote, "pretty strong track record" - the
same source that leaked the info about the
post-credits scene in the Avengers: Endgame
re-release, plus the news about the real Mandarin
appearing in Shang-Chi and the Legend of the
Ten Rings - it's just not possible to say
with any certainty how true this report really
is.
Another thing complicating the idea that Garfield
will portray Moon Knight in an upcoming Marvel
movie is the fact that he isn't the only person
said to be on Marvel's wishlist.
He's apparently only one of several names
Marvel is reportedly considering for the role,
and may have major competition in another
actor well-versed in the comic book movie
world.
We Got This Covered, citing the very same
source that's evidently a bottomless well
of Marvel-related information, has also claimed
that the studio is eyeing Joseph Gordon-Levitt,
the man behind police officer John Blake in
The Dark Knight Rises.
Like Garfield, Gordon-Levitt is Jewish, meaning
there's a chance that Marvel does have him
on its wishlist, if the outlet's other report
is to be believed.
As we've said, this is all speculation for
now.
Only time will tell if Marvel hands Moon Knight
the greatest gift of all - a solo movie - and
whether or not Garfield will be the lucky
guy to take the lead.
"You want me to come down there so you can
kill me?"
"Yes."
"I'll be right there."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.